let's go to Lucas from Brazil Brazil of
course will have a runoff election on
October 30th and things are quite wild
there Lucas what's going on
hello do you listen I can hear you
so I want to ask you about uh video you
made two months ago about Christina
kitchen
do you remember the video I do
well
it's kind of a hard question let's see
don't you think it was a bit
conspiratorial the video
yes I admit that in the video
I mean even the right wing media in
Brazil they hate Argentina they think
it's like far left or whatever they were
very insane that I mean it seems like
you did some Clinton Body Count but the
Christian about it yeah listen I mean I
say in the video uh it could absolutely
be perceived that way it's it's just you
know I I'm not pointing fingers at
anyone in particular just the entire
thing stinks to high heaven and uh I I
it's certainly not a unique you know
Argentinian media have have suggested it
and uh yeah but I I say in the video
it's conspiratorial without a doubt
the problem with breaking news uh
breaking news media coverage in general
you don't have Auto information and so
on for example I I it didn't have
anything to do with it being breaking I
still have the same opinion today I mean
and now it's you know it's been two
months so I don't know
but you still think that it was kind of
a fake flag today or I think it's
completely plausible this is one of the
most corrupt people in the history of
Argentinian Politics on the cusp of very
serious evidence being presented against
her and I would put nothing past her
morally for sure
okay so I guess you just a bit bite the
bullet on the conspiratory stuff I guess
I'm biting the bullet yep the frogs are
turning gay and everything you got me no
problem no problem uh one little
question about ranked choice of voting
do you think it's a good path forward or
I mean what do you have any take on it
yes I have a dozen videos about this
where I including go through the
different forms of it single
transferable vote and others and
generally speaking some version of
ranked Choice voting is very appealing
to me
I see uh well I guess that was my
questions thank you David all right
Lucas thank you and who do you support
in the upcoming election by the way
um in the second round rule about in the
first uh a politician named Zero Gomez
that didn't go very well okay fair
enough but Lula in this all right well
we're going to be watching it closely my
friend
good good thank you there's Lucas from
Brazil with a very very important
election upcoming